one of Chris Farley's sketches would
come to be a historic moment for
Saturday night life though audiences
wouldn't know it at the time the sketch
centers on a daytime talk show hosted by
Anna gasty with her guest played by Sher
o Terry complaining about her problems
raising her baby the baby in question is
predictably played by Farley who serves
as a force of chaos on the show and its
audience it only gets more absurd when
Tim medals enters as a child doctor only
to have both of his arms ripped off by a
manic Farley baby what makes to sketch
such an important moment for Saturday
Night Live is that according to Newsweek
it was the first sketch written by Tina
Fay to get on the air the future 30 Rock
Star was a newly hired writer in the
23rd season and will go on to make
history on the show as head Rider
Weekend Update anchor and six-time host